what's going on guys this is Rob and I
thought a kind of informal video would
be fun for this just because of the fact
that I wanted to do two things in this
video first thing I wanted to do is I
wanted to say thank you to all of you
guys 2023 has been an amazing year on on
Comics explain and that's because of the
Channel Growing and you guys watching
the videos and it's awesome I feel like
I'm back in the days when I had like
10,000 subscribers and I was making like
a thank you video or the thing like
you're supposed to do when you hit like
10,000 subscribers on YouTube but don't
mind you guys are certainly worthy of
the than the second thing that I want to
do here is I want to talk about my
favorite comic stories of the year and
what I'm looking forward to next year
here's the issue you guys hear from my
my beautiful sultry dulet tones almost
every day so what if it wasn't just
me what if it was other
people take it away hey guys I'm south
from the YouTube channel comic pop and
comic poop returns thank you to Rob for
letting me be a part of this it's always
nice to return to the LOM from when I
came because I don't if you know this
but Rob and I used to do this on a
regular basis like a weekly thing you
might say but I'm really excited to talk
about what my favorite things from comic
book media were in 2023 and what are
looking forward to in 2024 2023 as far
as the media is concerned there's two
schools that thought on that subject the
first of which is for me it's about the
comic books there were some incredible
comic books that came or completed in
2023 that are worthy of Celebration do a
Power Bomb uh the end of Gotham City
year 1 which was just mind-bendingly
good Wonder Woman Historia zari's
Daredevil run wrapped up so many great
comic books and I'm so looking forward
to more in 2024 but outside of the comic
book world as far as multimedia is
concerned movies TV video games I think
the winner has to be PS5 Spider-Man 2 I
was really looking forward to that game
I loved the first incarnation I love
miles morales's game this game was so
much fun to play I enjoyed it in every
respect the story was incredible I
actually didn't see a lot of these twist
and turns coming from the game there's a
couple moments maybe put the controller
down just go I cannot believe they're
doing this but the celebration for me is
just the immersion the feeling you get
when you're web slinging that for me is
just the thing I've been chasing my
entire life and I know that there's a
part of me that was playing those Arkham
games games and I loved those games I
think they were the height of superhero
video gaming but Spider-Man swooped in
took it away but I know I was playing
those games swinging around on the
grapple gun going but if only it was web
slinging and now I have it and for me
that was the most exciting one of my
favorite pieces of comic book media in
2023 as far as what I'm looking forward
to there's a ton that's coming out in
2024 I'm looking forward to seeing the
conclusion and I feel like there's no
way it can't be happening in 2024
although I've been wrong before of
Wolverine and Beast the Beast plot is
wrapping up in 20124 and I'm really
looking forward to that if you aren't
familiar Rob will explain it but there
has been this looming sort of damle over
Hank McCoy's head I don't know for what
like over a decade now more and I'm
really looking forward to seeing how
they wrap that up because I feel like
they've been really building in a great
way I'll tell you one other thing
chips sari's Batman zurar plot is
concluding very early in 2024 these are
things that I know are just right on the
horizon they're coming but I'm so
looking forward to those particular
story arcs coming to fruition by
accomplished writers and incredible
artists and I know that 2024 is going to
have more in store that I can't even
anticipate that's the fun and the joy of
comic books overall so thanks for having
me
happy New
Year oh I didn't see you there my name
is Ernie the blur without fear I have my
own little corner of YouTube carved out
for myself also called blur without fear
where I talk about comics and other
comic book related things what a year
2023 has been especially if you've been
reading comics for almost 40 years like
I have like Daniel Warren Johnson's
Transformer series which I mean we're
only two issues in but it's already off
to a great start and of course we got
more to look forward to with all the
other stuff coming out of the inner John
Universe like the Duke and Cobra
Commander series as well as more gii Joe
and other Transformer spin-offs it's
also been a banner year for the
community itself shout out to Rob for
being the Iron Man 2008 kicking off this
wild and wacky and zany Shenanigans
field comic book community that we have
on YouTube that has become like a home
to me and all of you out there in
YouTube land who lend your support to
comic book channels across the entire
site want to give a shout out and a
thank you to you Earth's real Mightiest
Heroes hey everyone Benny here known as
manga storian not that other guy I know
I look like that other guy but I'm manga
storian I talk about manga over at manga
storian and thank you Robin and his team
for inviting me to be here and be a part
of telling you guys what I loved about
2023 well let's kick it off from a manga
standpoint I enjoyed reading one piece
and I have now covered 800 chapters of
that over on my channel manga storian
but but since Rob is known for comic
books and stuff like that let's talk
about something comic book related I'm
actually a huge fan of Chip sidari's
Batman I stand by my statement it all
comes down to what zurar is and what the
reveal is going to be which is going to
happen in the year of 2024 apparently so
I guess I'm allowed to state that I
really enjoyed the Batman run of 2023
because I won't know if it was good or
not until January apparently uh video
game wise uh I was a huge fan of let's
see if you can guess it what game would
I be a huge huge fan of well of course
Gotham Knights yeah I know a lot of you
guys are going to argue with me and say
that Spider-Man 2 was the overall better
game and I agree with you but in this
year I got to play Gotham knights with
one of my buddies and it was a blast
wait was Gotham Knights this year you
know what I don't care if Gotham knights
was this year cuz I'm going to say
Gotham knights we all know that
Spider-Man 2 is the superior game but I
got a lot of good memories playing
Gotham Knights and I think it was this
year so I'm going to count that one in
General um and as far as movies go well
of course my favorite movie is going to
be Guardians of the Galaxy 3 concluded
the trilogy one of the best things that
came out of the MCU for this year close
second was Spider-Man but Spider-Man
left it on a cliffhanger so how do you
compete with that situation you know
what I mean and in terms of anime and
stuff like that since you know manga
storian go check out manga storian I
don't know who that comic storian guy is
just looks really close to me he just
doesn't have the glasses that's the
difference between us uh I actually
watched uh JoJo's Bizarre Adventure the
first like four seasons and it's
incredible and just makes you want to
walk around the house flexing all day I
also finally caught up on Witch of
mercury the Gundam series loved both of
those and also highly recommend so there
you go comic books manga stuff and while
we're at it Final Fantasy 14 still the
best MMO fight me about it wild fans
anyway guys I'll talk to you all next
time thank you again Rob and his crew
for inviting me to be a part of this and
uh hope you guys enjoyed 2023 so that
was dope I actually had a fan refer to
me as being on the mount Rush more of
comic book YouTubers I'm not quite sure
how to interpret that but it is awesome
to be in a position to be able to reach
out to a whole bunch of comic book
YouTubers and say hey guys let's make a
video where we talk about our favorite
comics of the year and what we're
looking forward to next year so my
little tidbit here as most of you guys
know I loved Jonathan Hickman's house
and powers of X what I've loved in 2023
was fall of X that's been my standout
Story So Far Gods is a little too early
to know how good it's going to be
because we're only a few issues in but I
have loved the fall of X and then
judgment day was really really good
there were some good stories that came
out for Marvel this year
DC you know it is what it is but
nonetheless for 2024 here's what I'm
hyped about number one the collapse of
the X-Men for those you guys who don't
know it's like the Fall of the House of
X and like the fall of the powers of X
or something along those lines basically
what Jonathan Hickman did is he House of
Ed the X-Men it's kind of we but it is
cool to see that they're basically
reshuffling restructuring and reworking
everything the next thing that I'm
really excited for is the return of
Ultimate Spider-Man you guys know
Jonathan Hickman is writing it and that
is my favorite comic book writer right
now in the entirety of the comic book
industry I'll read anything Jonathan
Hickman writes it's most likely going to
be a slow burn it's probably going to
take a few years for it to really kind
of tell its whole story no idea how long
he plans on writing it for but I do know
along the way it's gonna have some
ridiculously amazing moments so let me
know down in the comments section what
stories did you guys love from comic
books this year and what stories are you
excited to see next year and I will
catch you all later peace